[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la vérité est toute simple quand c'est
un homme bon c'est des erreurs de
jeunesse quand c'est une femme ses
faiblesses il serpente des cas une
virulence très forte des critiques après
son meeting être eu la même virulence à
l'égard d'un homme
sur la forme on en attend toujours
beaucoup plus des femmes en politique
que des hommes et j'ai trouvé que en
général quand il s'agit de femmes
politiques que ce soit valérie pécresse
mais anne hidalgo ou d'autres on
concentre les commentaires et les
analyses sur des questions de forme de
voix d'attitude et c est beaucoup moins
sur le fond il ya ces vérités
parfois d'autres candidats
on aurait pas de l'avis d'un candidat
masculin et que ce n'est pas correct
mais j'avoue que l'utilisation récurrent
de l'argument du machisme dans toutes
circonstances mais en ce qui me concerne
assez étrange et machisme en politique
comme dans
une dernière
très forte il ya une forme de domination
masculine va qui a été dénoncée que nous
dénonçons donc oui ça existe bien sûr
elle la tire
elle la tourner
elle la bifurk
elle oriente
elle lui appuie dans le dos dans le
premier tweet aldi par ordre
chronologique voici ce qui arrive aux
femmes entre guillemets sandrine
rousseau une folle doublée d'une idiote
anne hidalgo on dit d'elle qui vaut
mieux en rire tellement alors là je vois
plus rien si vous pouvez mettre le
carton en plus gros on entend tellement
elle est nulle christiane taubira c'est
le vide intellectuel doublé d'un ego
elle la pousse
et elle peut lui faire un triple axel
j'ai discuté avec donald trump pendant
une demi heure on a on a évoqué nos
campagnes respectives les leçons qu'on
en tire est non c'est bien qu'ils aient
au téléphone l'ancien président des
états unis tant mieux pour lui j'espère
que donald trump se porte bien nous
avons une chose en commun
monsieur trump veut que les états unis
d'amérique reste les états unis
d'amérique et moi je veux que la france
reste la france on a pris c'est cet
appel avec beaucoup de plaisir parce que
c'est une personne est un modèle non
dans la plein de points communs à bord
eric zemmour n'a pas de modèle ou en
tout cas si un modèle en termes de
politique étrangère c'est le général de
gaulle il m'a dit de rester moi même que
les médias allaient me qualifiée de
brutale mais que je devais être sincère
je voudrais demander à ceux qui qui
opère la stratégie de la limace de bien
vouloir accélérer leur départ merci
beaucoup et ce soir nouvelles tensions
entre les camps le pen et zemmour
nicolas des suspendus de toutes ses
fonctions au sein du rassemblement
national notamment celle de porte-parole
du parti il est accusé d'avoir transmis
des informations confidentielles à
l'entourage d'eric zemmour un salon de
coiffure vandalisée à nice le nom de
l'enseignent eric zemmour l'homonyme du
candidat d'extrême droite en activité
depuis une trentaine d'années en
provence alpes côte d'azur s'inquiète du
climat de violence ni et la campagne
présidentielle incroyable ce qui s'est
passé cette inédite
captée par de la vidéosurveillance au
mexique les oiseaux sont peut-être alors
il ya les vétérinaires qui ont accouru
sur place pour savoir d'où ça pouvait
venir les oiseaux sont peut-être est
mort suite à l'inhalation de fumées
toxiques
[Musique]
et